a huge controversy has exploded after
Google has fired an employee who wrote
an internal memo criticizing the
diversity policy of Google the employers
name is James d'amour and according to
him he was fired for perpetuating gender
stereotypes google agrees Google CEO
sundar Pichai sent the note to employees
which said that portions of the memo
written by this employee quote violate
our code of conduct and crossed the line
by advancing harmful gender stereotypes
in our workplace going on to say we are
unequivocal in our belief the diversity
and inclusion are critical to our
success as a company will continue to
stand for that and to be committed to it
for the long haul so there's not really
any debate as to why James d'amour was
fired
what did d'amours memo actually say it
said a few things number one it accused
google of silencing conservative
political opinion it argued that there
are biological differences that play a
role in the shortage of women in
technology and in leadership positions
and it has led to so much nonsense and
also some thoughtful comments on the
internet and there's a few issues here
and we should sort of handle them one
white by one because the story has
become a total s storm a crappy storm I
guess I could call it and lots of the
reaction is both confused and apoplectic
so before we even get into the actual
issues here some people are just against
diversity in the workplace and they're
against equality and egalitarian ISM and
they're just going to defend anyone
who's also against those things I
personally pat don't even think it's
worth engaging with those people or
debating that part that's not the
interesting thing to me there's no
surprise that there's alright internet
trolls who are just against diversity in
the worst workplace and they do believe
that there should be significant
separation between men and women based
on the type of job that someone is doing
I don't really care about those people
these aren't necessarily the people who
are just against affirmative action at
all costs or just think that you know a
workplace should be hiring people
entirely based on meritocracy it seems
like it's another level beyond that it
is absolutely and I I so I don't think
it's even relevant most of our core
audience there's probably some people on
our YouTube channel that
sort of sensitive to that I don't think
our core audience is so let's go through
the step-by-step first of all did Google
do something legally wrong here probably
not Google is a company that has
internal policies which as long as they
don't violate Employment
non-discrimination law are what they are
so I'm reminded of when Mozilla CEO
Brendan something I don't even remember
the guy's name at this point he was sort
of forced into resignation after it was
revealed he made donations to an
anti-gay candidate or cause there was
nothing illegal there right Mozilla
determined that that was an individual
that wasn't good for their brand and the
person moved on and no crime took place
despite significant outgrow outcry from
the anti-gay right similarly here Google
has determined that this type of
ideology which clearly must exist in
others at Google as well given the size
of Google and the number of employees
that they have that this was sent to
around 50,000 employees was memo by
James d'amour that this wasn't something
that worked for them it indicated that
there was not a good fit between this
employee and them if there was no
contract and as long as he wasn't let go
on the basis of race or ethnicity
national origin sexual orientation in
states where that's protected whatever
the case may be then there is nothing
illegal that took place here although
d'amour is saying he's exploring legal
options it does not appear than anything
illegal took place here that's number
one
and obviously this isn't a free speech
issue because it has to do with the
government coming down on your right to
speak publicly of course and when you
talk about a private business I mean
they have every right to do this and it
doesn't mean that you know because you
can say whatever you want that there's
not going to be negative consequences or
that you're not going to look like a
fool online no question about it so at
the core of it I don't really believe
Google cares that much about this one
person's opinion they care about how its
manifesting at work because what they
care about is profit and what they care
about is the public image and what they
care about is a working environment that
is going to lead to the most
productivity and profit as possible one
senior Google employee wrote a blog post
about this and he said particularly
talking about the engineering department
engineering is all about cooperation
collaboration and empathy for both your
colleagues and your customers this
employee wrote something that would
directly negatively impact that in
Google's view so they fired him now
do I agree with firing people for having
different political views not as a
principle although certainly if it's a
political organization which Google
isn't there's a really good reason why
everyone should be on the same page
politically and political belief is not
a protected class
according to employment discrimination
law and it seems like right-wingers
would be the people who are attacking
Google right now because of the subject
matter right and because you know they
think that it violates free speech even
at its core but also private businesses
have the autonomy to do whatever they
want and I thought that Republicans were
all for that Republicans should be
defending a business's right to make
decisions about who they want working
for them presuming that it doesn't
violate the law and it doesn't appear
that this does so then there are
questions about whether this is part of
some broader destructive identity
politics or tribalism are almost
indicative of like a dogmatic religious
type adherence to the ideals of
diversity and multiculturalism at Google
maybe and we could criticize that but
again this is a private company if you
don't like the ideals if you're mad that
Google has decided to get rid of James
the more because of this memo go boycott
Google you don't have to use Google and
if you find it difficult to boycott
Google because their products are
ubiquitous then maybe you should have
been concerned all along that Google was
getting too big and that there were
monopolies related issues that you
should have been worrying about for a
long time but again that is a different
issue here I also think that the firing
might have something to do with a lack
of judgment because it may not even be
the subject matter as it is just
releasing a memo that gets circulated
around 50,000 people I don't know what
the chain of command is like at Google
because obviously there's a New Age
liberal type company but it just doesn't
seem like the the smart way to go about
expressing your opinion to the entire
company and again there would be nothing
illegal about Google using that as a
basis to say this is not someone who's
going to work for us lastly there's this
idea that men and women are different
and that this could lead to one or the
other biological sex being better
predisposed to engineering jobs
I don't reject that on principle right I
don't reject on principle remember when
we had Larry Summers at Harvard say
something about you know we should be
exploring whether there is a
predisposition to
words being a better or worse that I
don't remember it was math or science or
whatever based on being male or female
I actually am totally open to the idea
of exploring that I mean it we should be
allowed to ask those questions and
research them fairly because after all
if there are differences in terms of
one's predisposition to engineering or
whatever job type we're talking about as
humans we should want to know that I do
not believe that discrimination along
gender lines should be allowed but I do
believe that silencing people who want
to explore those questions shouldn't be
something that is done as a policy and
it shouldn't be done out of political
correctness or any other knee-jerk
reaction that is very different than
saying Google has done something illegal
by determining they don't want this
person working for them
boycott Google that is Google is free to
make the hiring decisions and firing
decisions at once and along the same
lines you are free to use or not use
Google services we don't have to like
how this turned out Pat but my question
is what are the people that are
apoplectic over this suggesting be done
and I don't know what the answer is
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership